uh
ugh
[Music]
i'm thinking about turning these
adventures into songs after we're done
hopefully this song will be sung for
years to come by the people of monstat
just like the legend of vanessa
i have loved that song since i was small
how are you feeling today honorary night
i am completely prepared and fully
confident that we can do this
even master de luca convened us to the
very end despite only being an
accidentally involved bystander
you shared your secret with me and i
only returned your trust to the same
extent
it's freedom
freedom when you first arrived at
monstat did no one tell you that monstat
is the city of freedom
she really is a child of freedom monstat
is a romantic city without the reign of
a king and its citizens enjoy the most
freedom amongst the seven nations i hope
the dragon that once protected monstat
will soon be free too no one should have
deceived him by telling him that monstat
betrayed him
and no one should have told him that it
was his eternal duty to protect the city
he has the right and freedom to choose
his own way of life fenty well then
traveler may the thousands of years of
wind that have blown through monstat go
with you
just like the last time i shall channel
animal energy for you
oh no wonder you said his voice sounds
familiar
[Music]
what
look there are two shiny spots onto
vollen's back
they appear to be poisonous blood clots
that have coagulated on his wounds
the abyss order must have cursed the
wounds
that's what's corrupting devolen's mind
to save divalen we're going to have to
get rid of those blood clots
aim for those blood clots
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is getting away but i'm familiar with
his tactics just hold on a bit longer
i'll extract and condense the pure
animal from the shots being fired
shattering them will create acceleration
currents
i can't control where they will appear
so keep your eyes peeled
i'm sorry this is hurting you
so
so
now we can fight the ball in on equal
grounds
the grandest bard is here to help
but first let me be clear
even after hundreds of years without use
defaulin's teeth and claws are still
very dangerous
now
aim for the tainted blood clot on his
neck
ugh
this is the ball and face in the hole
celestine finale termini
this dragon has strange tastes when it
comes to naming things
i named it for him just now
seriously
well anyway
let's ride the wind currents and stay
away from the breaking platforms
the energy flooding out from the
fissures will be hot be sure to watch
your step
huh
uh
here we go
[Music]
aim for the tainted blood clot on his
neck
[Music]
brace yourself
[Music]
huh
here we go
now is our chance aim for the tainted
blood clot on his neck
think you can get away
here we go
[Music]
do
it's been a while since we flew like
this together
honda vol
just now
why
why did you not ask me to protect you
like the last time me not wanting you to
listen to the abyss order doesn't mean
that you have to listen to me
freedom if demanded of you by an archon
is really no freedom at all
[Music]
is this
the power of the animal arkhan
but i am no longer part of the four
winds
even if that's so you still protected us
regardless
now spread your wings of freedom and go
with my blessing
and so
the storm terror threat was quilled
i clarified the misunderstanding to the
citizens of monstat
and let them know that they are safe to
them it seems storm terror attacked
monsta out of nowhere
and vanished just as quickly they must
be finding the whole ordeal very
confusing however
winds change their course
someday
they will blow towards a brighter future
[Music]
foreign
you guys are back
the honorary night returns triumphant
yep we're back from tussling with the
volume
you just returned yesterday right gene
got back first and she told us all about
your heroic deeds uh i wonder if i'll
ever get an opportunity like that
that doesn't come into it you guys
deserve all the credit for how you
resolved this crisis
when i brought you into the city that
day i was just doing my duty as an
outrider
you're welcome
but have you been waiting for us here
this whole time
of course not just because i'm not out
on the front line doesn't mean i don't
have work to do in fact i'm dealing with
the aftermath of the crisis as we speak
aftermath
here
what happened in monstat
while master gene was away the monsters
lurking nearby made a coordinated attack
on the city
fortunately we weren't completely taken
by surprise i detected the hilly charles
we're moving closer to the city a while
back oh yeah
hi mama members when we first met you
were clearing out one of their camps
exactly and if we hadn't started making
preparations back then monstat would be
in much greater danger by now
me too but i have a strange feeling that
we're not out of the woods yet
hilly charles aren't usually capable of
coordinating like this
our best guess is that the abyss order
is behind it
they've taken over the hilly charles
hmm
good thing we saved avalon or they might
have taken him too
that's right and since i'm the outrider
it's up to me to keep eyes on the abyss
order from now on
oh i'm sorry you should be celebrating
your victory not listening to all this
somber talk
hmm
i promise to take you out for some
sticky honey roast didn't i before
everyone got caught up in the storm
terror crisis
there's no time like the present right
you guys hungry
you bet you may have forgotten till just
now but it's been on pinewood's mind
this whole time
awesome let's go it's been way too long
since i last ate a sticky honey roast
myself
wait for me a good hunter i'll be right
there i just have to clean up here real
quick